und diese meldung hier ist gerade mal
drei minuten alt in einem nördlichen
bezirk der ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
ist es zu gefechten gekommen auch
explosionen waren im stadtteil polonski
zu hören wie ein journalist der
nachrichtenagentur ap berichtete
menschen rannten demnach weg um sich in
sicherheit zu bringen und schüsse waren
dem ap reporter zufolge dort auch zu
hören oh ja und bis ins stadtzentrum
hinein auch größere explosionen die
russischen streitkräfte die rücken bei
ihren grossangriff auf die ukraine
derzeit also auf die hauptstadt vor und
wie groß muss die verzweiflung dort sein
das ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium fordert
zivilisten in einem tweet auf mit
molotow cocktails gegen russische panzer
vorzugehen macht molotow-cocktails
neutralisiert die besatzer heißt es in
diesem tweet mit molotow cocktails gegen
panzer die ganze dramatik der situation
zeigt sich auch in diesen bildern
sondern ja diese menschen hier die wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen sind
krankenschwestern sind gerade ja frisch
gebackene mütter mit ihren säuglingen
mit ihren babys in einem
luftschutzbunker eines krankenhauses
auch sie mussten sich natürlich in
sicherheit bringen hier sehen wir die
krankenschwester wie sie das neugeborene
umsorgt alle sind dick eingewickelt in
decken weil dort ist es natürlich auch
sehr sehr kalt erschreckende bilder von
dort und sie sehen oben rechts
eingebildete eingeblendet das ist der
meydan der hauptplatz in
kiew und der ist menschenleer sonst sind
da hunderte tausende menschen unterwegs
und jetzt ist er leer und da kommen dann
gleich noch technische dinge dar ein als
wenn man es gar nicht zeigen will
technikern ein gutes stichwort
wahrscheinlich nämlich zu einem it
techniker einem deutschen thorsten
peters und der sitzt in der ukraine fest
er war eigentlich nur dort um zu
arbeiten hier sehen wir ihnen herr peter
sind wie es die situation momentan
kommen sie nicht zurück nach deutschland
schaffen sie es nicht
momentan muss noch gar keine klaren
dafür vorhanden
keinen keine möglichkeit irgendwie hier
wegzukommen es gibt keine hilfe seitens
der deutschen regierung
und ohne spielt ohne sich in gefahr zu
begeben
glauben sie mir hier furchtbar sagt
peter sind wie sind sie überhaupt
dorthin gekommen warum sind sie dort und
ist ihre familie bei ihnen
nein ich bin alleine ich habe hier
sollen ihren job ausführen im
technikbereich
und da hat mich dann aber daraufhin
frühe hingegeben als ich eigentlich
musste weil ich mich mit den
gegebenheiten vertraut machen wollte
haben wir das land angeschaut jetzt da
und ja dann kam es dass die materialien
nicht angekommen sind dann wurde es
immer schlimmer und schlimmer natürlich
auch schon längst das land verlassen
können aber als dann die truppen sind
abgezogen worden da gehen alle davon aus
dass es einfach einen streich war
einfach ein geschenk
ausgeübt wurde und es gab eine einigung
dann kann es eben halt anders als da
sind wir müssen sie leider kurz
unterbrechen denn wir müssen zu unseren
kollegen paul ronzheimer geben wir hören
uns aber gleich wieder bleiben sie bitte
in der leitung paul es gibt bei die
aktuelle entwicklungen was ist los ja es
gibt breaking news hier wird das zentrum
nur wenige kilometer von hier entfernt
ist bestätigt das ist russische truppen
gibt es gibt bereits feuergefecht und
wir sehen hier auf dieser strecke die
menschen die aus der stadt die aus kehrt
in diesem moment fliehen auf der anderen
seite also autos die noch in richtung
stadtrat wenige kilometer von ihr
entfernt die fluchten sich noch
dramatisch zu dem moment wo wir auf
erste panzer sehen die offenbar in der
innenstadt von trier sind und höhere aus
der stadt kampf farben hören schlüssel
ist scheint loszugehen beim großen kampf
um die hauptstadt
heute morgen hat für sprachen gab es
noch die leise hoffnung dass vielleicht
die russischen truppen die hauptstadt
nur umzingeln würden um dann druck zu
machen und zu verhandeln das scheint
sich also jetzt tatsächlich zu
zerschlagen da schaltet sich zunächst
zerschlagen das sind die berichte die
wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bekommen von
denen gehören und visa sowie in kiew das
ist nur wenige kilometer entfernten und
darf
raus geht aus der stadt thomas das sind
tausende menschen in diesem moment die
ukrainische hauptstadt verlassen wollen
aus angst dass jetzt der große angriff
russlands losgeht dass der große angriff
der russischen armee auf die ukrainische
hauptstadt in diesen minuten mit
begonnen hat begonnen kann man nicht
sagen denn es gibt ja bereits seit einem
tag artillerie moerser all das immer
wieder aber jetzt geben
endlose schlange endlose schlagen die
menschen hier ist panik in klinische
hauptstadt jetzt verlassen wollen paul
nun sind ja die ganzen männer zwischen
18 und 60 jahren aufgerufen worden zu
den waffen zu gehen theoretisch dürften
die gar nicht flüchten oder gehen das
heißt also sind viele werden einfach nur
ihre frauen und kinder heraus schicken
jetzt nein das ist so weil thomas das
die 18 bis 60 jährigen nicht die das
land verlassen dürfen sie dürfen
weiterhin in der ukraine unterwegs sein
und es gibt noch keine einbürgerung
aller männer bislang gibt es nur die
weisung dass die 18 bis 60 jährigen das
land nicht verlassen dürfen also sie
dürfen zb jetzt nicht in diesem moment
nach polen fliegen aber diese kolumne
geht heraus aus kiew raus aus der
hauptstadt einige werden auch versuchen
eine umliegende städte erstmals ein flug
zu suchen da haben wir viele kleine
hotels gesehen die komplette sind das
sind die ersten flüchtlinge hier die man
in diesem moment sieht vielen dank
es wird wahrscheinlich stunden wenn
nicht tage dauern bis die menschen raus
sind bei diesem kilometerlangen staus
die wir im übrigen auch gestern schon
gesehen haben die gestern ja bereits
begonnen habe